herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich sitze hier zusammen mit luca
ich saß jetzt wollen wir jetzt ist
kleine luca nur noch das wäre ich wieder
zurück und mir ist aufgefallen dass
irgendwie letzter zeit auf youtube super
viele sma videos sind und nicht mal
gesehen hat ja jeder von uns das schon
mal deshalb dachte ich mir machen wir
mal eine challenge mit dem ganzen und
zwar versuche ich zu erraten was
menschen essen in sma videos ich habe
dafür den kleinen clip vorbereitet
bekommen wo man hört wie die leute essen
und kurz danach kriegen wir eingeblendet
was die leute er müsse aber sagen du
hast dir nicht vorbereitet sondern eine
person hat ihn vorbereitet und wir
wissen noch beide nicht was auf uns
zukommen wird exakt wir müssen beide
raten einfach ich bin richtig gespannt
ich finde es aber oft übertrieben eklig
ich finde es sehr interessant dass also
bei mir wirkt es nicht entspannt also
für mich jetzt einfach nur zu was läuft
aber es gibt wirklich auch leute die
dann sagen wenn einer nicht direkt ein
das ist bei crazy ich glaube ist noch da
der begriff an sich bedeutet dass man so
ein kribbeln auf der kopfhaut bekommt
weil man geräusche
ich weiß nicht genau wir klicken auf
play in 321 kekse essen ich glaub ich
glaube das ist so ein apfel kekse
glaubst du echte aber das leder so dass
sich so die zähne sind durch das in
sechs wechsel
die ich nie gehören weiter ich sage es
ist irgendwie apfel leute es ist das ist
ganz komisch ich finde wenn er ab weil
es sich an wie ein keks aber wenn erst
dann kaut sie sagen eine gurke sie
einfach gurken kickte junge aber das
klingt ja so scheußlich wenn der dax ok
gelassen es ist man weiter auch nicht
wundert dass wir noch nichts wissen es
gibt noch nichts zu sehen
das ist also ich weiß nicht wie man das
auf jetzt komme ich mit sehen was es ist
jetzt kommt die auflösung
das heißt sind dass man schnell los ja
das war sicher nicht so so knackig an
oder das klingt ja ich will dich so das
ist glaube ich also mehr janina montes
reagierten platz eins interesse der
erste punkt geht an die janina weil du
hast eine süßigkeit gesagt du kriegst
einen viertel punkt okay
als nächste sache jetzt hören wir hin
passt das war schon okay moment hey ich
habe überhaupt kein spiel das man
nochmal okay der haut sich das rein wer
das letzte das ich kämpfe das original
original das sind die geräusche wenn
jemand in so einem mittelalter filme ja
sonst nicht so eine heute oder so ich
sage das ist ein apfel ich sage so ein
braten oder fleisch isst fleisch oder
schicken
also der punkt an dem ich auf jeden fall
ist fleisch aber also nichts gegen die
leute die das feiern jeder hat ja andere
so keine ahnung was vorlieben aber ich
wäre ungern leuten zu die chicken wings
es in the hudson wir haben das jetzt
also die optimale wirkung erst mal wenn
du zwei kopfhörer auf hass und stellen
ab und kriegst du von beiden ohren so
klaglos sieht dann auch zu geschmatzt
alter schon krank junge aber wieder auch
reinhaut wir können sich richtig denn
genauso
das grauen vor nein nein das ist also
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung ich habe
kein scheiß ich habe bei marshmallows
habe ich gedacht dass werden kings bei
chicken wings habe ich gedacht das wäre
ein apfel ich muss eigentlich das
gegenteil denken von dem man dass ich
denke das ist richtig schwer so schwer
da hab ich mir noch mal von vorne
das ist so schlimm das ist so richtig so
das muss so etwas sein was so richtig so
weich und matschig ist und er schlürft
so ausland oder so aber die kaufmann aus
dann also hast du irgendeine vorstellung
was es sein könnte ich ganz im ernst ich
sage wieder apfel aber stimmst du mir zu
das ist wohl einmalig sein wollen oder
sollen wir sagen dass ich jetzt sage
frucht und du da keine ahnung was weil
man kann es nicht ganz genau wir
probieren es einfach zu beschreiben was
wir hören die beschreibung die näher
dran ist kriegt den punkt okay doch ich
weiß es ich glaub ich weiß es also ich
würde sagen das ist so was wie so ein
bison 40 oder sowas bei der jeweilig
haben gehört dass er irgendwie etwas und
so fachkreisen und was schläft weil er
auch flüssigkeit drin ist also ich würde
sagen ich mir frucht aber er so in die
richtung für sich oder pflaume oder
irgendwie beweist außerdem sind ja nicht
mehr aber was irgendwie sowas zu klebrig
ist bei ich hier schreibe ich weiß in
die alter was ist sowie fällt ja gerade
nichts ein aber ich hab so ich weiß es
wirklich nicht will einfach sagen es ist
wirklich so was vergisst ich sage dass
klebrig du wachst du sagst mir frucht so
hey leute was pizza das ist der gleiche
typ regatta league wäre da selbst ruhig
überlegt mal was macht er für videos was
das für keinerlei ich mache jetzt mal
ein video ist eine pizza und chicken
wings man hat ja gar keine chance das zu
erhalten
jetzt habe ich auch richtig bock zum sma
video zu machen verpasste bestellen ja
selbst bestellen also nicht so reinhauen
so leute warten wir mal weiter da kommt
schon die nächste sache
der original es hört sich alles manchmal
noch einmal zurück was mit augen zu und
versuche das vorzustellen
ich glaube ich habe was ich glaube dass
irgendein beamter wir haben schon die
auch schon gesehen ich hätte jetzt
gesagt ist es irgendwas mit richtig viel
soße sind pommes mit soße ich gedacht
aber nudeln da geht die kammer nach es
ist so dass das klingt aber auch nicht
wirklich jemanden normali also das ist
echt ganz übel das ist so krank schwer
das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht ich
hätte auch gedacht dass das so easy
da kommt man so viel scheiße der nächste
sagt linz oder bei mir ich glaube
diesmal ist es gemüse bei dir was an
ganz weit weg
bei mir was direkt auf einer couch
nochmal ich glaube ich habe also
manchmal zu beginn so an denen ich wieso
einen keks oder ein apfel beißt ja so
lange daran dass ich habe meine idee es
mit spezifischen wird bestimmt nicht
stimmen aber daran denke ich denke an
diese kramp canceln pokals nehme ja
genau wir weisen diese weißen krabben
chips soll das würde so perfekt passen
irgendwie zu dem geräusch ich würde
wieder sagen die doch ich sage wieder
das sind irgendwelche kekse auf jeden
fall war das ist ein schütze kein wunder
dass ich sie nicht gehört habe wenn ich
auf einer seite okay bei einem punkt ist
ganz normal ich glaube es sind ganz
normale chips ja ich hätte eigentlich
okay leute ich würde sagen der sieger
des heutigen tage ist wird von euch
entschieden schreibt einfach alle die
kommentare wer gewonnen hat die sache
ist schreibt auch die kommentare konnte
die jugend etwas davon
schreibt mir kommen oder gerade in die
kommentare dann sehen wir beim nächsten
video wieder bis dahin war es gut